[Music]
[Applause]
I've been hearing about this QE
challenge for a personally I prefer
mango over Kiwi but you shouldn't remind
them of the sisters yeah I'm here
the only reason I did that is just to
get you attention otherwise I'm just
gonna do a general reminder now Brahmas
sisters it'll reminder for me to you
guys and all reminders have been going
about inshallah but one thing that's
really important I didn't know nothing
about is Kiwi challenge from you either
kikyo is caught but i've seen a lot and
obviously when you click on these things
sometimes the music automatically plays
are obviously you turn off because first
I washed it I was thinking what is this
about after that now I got to certain
pages where you expect it those who are
not practicing you go and you see okay
everyone's gonna go over to try and
anyone who wants to be a part of it
etc but when you go to pages that you
don't expect it which they either give
you stomach reminders whoever it may be
I'm not talking to anyone specifically
I've seen a lot few people doing it as
well one thing you guys need to
understand brothers and sisters is that
music was the biggest fitna for me in my
jaw Helia I heard that in two three
places and I swear to god it was stuck
in my head for one week Kiki whatever it
was stuck in my head and me even
mentioned it to you I'm sure it comes to
a head as well
this is how damaging music is you know
if I'm not mistaken it was even claimed
that said God and and music do not stay
in the same heart that's reminder number
one to all my brothers and sisters and
myself first number two who are these
people now what I'd be calling to what
they caught is the most filthy spin ever
heard on relationships I don't know what
had the lyrics for you but I know it's
talking to her our relationship here is
talking about her ah Malaysia is
glorifying it brothers and sisters these
are the things that cause what I believe
me
Xena just doesn't happen like that it
all happens for in stages jiangshan see
that's why I lost want Allah said do not
even come close to it and these music
get you in this love mode this melody
mode we start imagine this guy or this
girl you lie and all this kind of stuff
brothers and sisters wallahi it's a
reminder to myself don't jump on every
band well can you see everything that
happens don't jump on it so it's just a
reminder for me Allah
hello darkness my old friend who the
fort this guy's gonna be behind the
scene now I bless him mashaallah we're
gonna be recording something special for
mistaken
definitely but by the way Kiki doesn't
love you Allah loves you and I'll always
stick by you Kiki Kiki will leave you
Kiki will testify against you under
their judgement so love the one you
deserves it your Lord sisters take a
chance with your friends and family and
don't get subscribe to my family